iris mais tonnerre s'est confié sur les
propos sexy dont elle a été victime pour
les plateaux télé ces dernières années
elle explique que ces attaques
concerneraient principalement sa façon
de s'habiller
oui vous avez même problème une femme
tout simplement on a facilement envie de
nous voir en jupe ou pantalon
moi j'ai eu déjà plusieurs fois
l'expérience sur quelques plateaux où on
dit tu es beaucoup en pantalon mettrait
pas une petite jupe la prochaine fois tu
veux mais après ça c'est un truc qui tue
aussi vachement chez les miss c'est que
déjà pendant notre année on nous demande
ça et j'ai été deux fois sur deux
événements en pantalon nous dit bon la
prochaine fois c'est comme si tu mets
une robe les gens vous voient la miss
avec une robe et des talons ça c'est
comme vous j'en ai marre en bermuda mais
non moi j'en ai marre qu'on crie le
sexisme pour tout et n'importe quoi ou
alors elle est animatrice elle a des
producteurs ses producteurs ils ont le
droit de décider comment elle s'habille
ou non s'il est pas contenté de faire
notre métier et c'est pas une question
de femmes ou pas fan mais regardez
regardez sur danse avec les stars y
avait des hommes il ya des beaux gosses
à chaque saison on leur demande de se
mettre torse nu les six noms n'ont ni
pourrais je me cimon a donné alors là je
suis d'accord et c'est vrai qu'ils
devaient répondre s'il vous plaît parce
que moi aussi si guillaume genton a
complètement même moi je suis désolé
combien de fois j'ai 10 h il mieux avec
des vestes d'aider les chemises raymond
plein de fois on a parlé de son look
non mais c'est vrai ils sont donc faut
arrêter c'est la même chose pour les
filles et pour les garçons là dessus je
l'a vraiment la chute pas d'accord avec
ça fait d'accord et puis c'est une très
belle femme donc évidemment sans être
sexiste si elle est un peu apprêtée bien
sûr que ça va être mieux pour l'émission
ça va attirer les téléspectateurs y a
rien de sexiste l'attend dans les
coffres mais lorsque vous avez des
invités sur un plateau télé que des
femmes viennent elles vont pas tous de
venir en col roulé je dirais des invités
c'est une animatrice sur une rue glamour
et d'amour en col roulé bien évidemment
non mais s'il vous plaît là vous êtes en
train de tout niké mais on va dire
bye-bye autant je pouvais entendre la
rue rosillo pas longtemps le tiens il
faut qu'on arrive avec tous les
attributs dehors
moi je peux entendre un producteur et
qui vous insultent après prix tu rentres
dans le salon des gens j'ai envie de te
voir d'une certaine façon parce que dans
la logique oui on s'habille pas pareil à
18h à 20h pour un prime pour un ou pour
un access et c'est donc ça c'est une
logique de production autant ton
argument là qui dit c'est une fille donc
il faudrait un décolleté own goal dans
un col roulé ces lâches pas du tout
d'accord avec pour un homme
on envie qu'il soit en costume bleu elle
et moi par exemple on voit personne a
livré à moi-même non oui quel rigolo
dans ça dans sa prise de position c'est
que sur instagram et lyng très très
dénudée finalement à la télé a dit que
finalement c'est sexiste quand on lui
demande d'être un sous marin voulez oui
mais l'avait l'incident et puis quand
mais je demande c'est son choix c'est à
dire qu'une femme elle dit bah moi je me
déshabille quand je le décide
et si à la télé j'ai paumé ben j'ai pas
envie voilà j'ai envie d'avoir la vie de
kelly là dessus je pense que c'est le
moi mon avis ce que déjà moi je trouve
que pernikoff il a raison de dire que
leur panse voilà j'ai la mairie jelavic
aux joueurs de foot dirait bien que la
cause de la paix pernik oui c'est pour
ça je suis mais mais mais nicolas
nicolas il dit ce qu'ils pensaient ce
que beaucoup pensent et on va pas faire
les langues de bois un moment donné moi
je suis pas spécialement d'accord parce
que moi je suis contente de m'habiller
comme j'ai envie de m'habiller et iris
haussier à la raison comme dit géraldine
sur instagram elle le décide
après ce qu'elle avait koala du mal
c'est quand on lui dit tu tamis comme ça
là c'est vrai que c'est des migrants
mais il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
pensent comme nicolas quand on glisse à
une femme moi je vais vous dire un
producteur que ce soit au mali
c'est lui qui décide des tenues v5 oui
au docteur wi fi des civils arabes
dupouy maintenant c'est quoi le
conducteur le producteur il m'a dit ah
bah faut que la femme elle soit remplacé
mon devoir c'est bon je suis désolé oui
d'accord c'est que voilà la série de la
femme de moins de 35 ans gaulle et on va
lui demander globalement une montre
montre qu'en décolleté ème jour
on n'a jamais demandé à quelqu'un je
vais prendre mon exemple personnel moi
quand j'ai été découvertes sur tf1
j'avais moins de 30 ans et et on m'a
demandé d'arriver comme je le sentais à
l'époque c'était bataille et fontaine et
j'arrivais tous les jours enfin à chaque
émission en courant sur le plateau en
tailleur pantalon et des baskets et ça a
été ma marque de fabrique et on a et on
s'est dit ça correspond à l'émission ça
correspond à l'image qu'on a envie de la
fille est un peu fraîche
voilà et on n'a pas été me dire c'est
que si qqun pour qu'ils changent emporté
ma nouvelle robe moulante et c'est donc
il ya aussi voilà en fonction de
l'adéquation du et puis on peut parler
avec son producteur aussi à bien
mais virer tout à fait je me sens pas à
l'aise tu me dérange quelque chose
peut-être que l'on peut trouver un
compromis et c'est enfin voilà bien sûr
moi je suis désolé c'est voilà c'est le
produit des gens qui décident exactement
oui bord qui décide du contenu des
missions et qui décide au script de
comment les personnes sadou pas isabelle
moi je suis entièrement d'accord à ce
que vous avez dit ce qu'elle dit
guillaume là dessus et en plus j'ose
espérer qu'il y met une petite dose
d'humour parce que quand on a le
physique des risques mais parfois un
minimum de ça devient indécent au bout
d'un moment de dire c'est c'est un
cauchemar quand même comme conseil
m'habiller comme ci ou comme ça c'est 60
commerces et sa carrière ratée arrive
également d'amener les jeunes à des gens
totalement la joueuse rmi-rsa sur
twitter en tout cas les téléspectateurs
10 c'est le producteur qui décident
point barre regardez moi vous même en
des termes et par exemple moi je vous
dise que les a il y avait au pays il y
avait un il y avait des stylistes avant
pour léonie coeur j'ai demandé à ce
qu'il soit enlevé
j'ai dit je veux qu'ils soient habillés
comme dans la vraie vie c'est vrai comme
ils sont dans la vraie vie lorsque les
rues qui sont je veux qu'ils aient leur
style voilà sinon forcément bien voilà
s'il fait c'est comme ceci voilà oui
mais faut pas mélanger parce que nous
ici on s'habille comme on veut mais faut
pas dire patron et producteur tu peux
pas dans une société normale dire à une
femme citée patron pascal à mettre à
terre de direction néanmoins j'aimerais
bien que c'est là où je veux en venir
jouer à dire que votre métier avoué et c
est pourquoi l faut pas les emmener dans
les propos de gens qui vont au vélo
normalement éliminés mais ces images tu
es là pour faire rêver tu es là pour
faire kiffer tu es là pour que ce soit
joli à l'image gardez vous la trouvez
vous la preuve nous c'est pas encore un
bon exemple ici mais d'habitude en télé
ils prennent que des bonnes meufs
j'ai des bonnes meufs
[Rires]
hahaha
[Applaudissements]
ton camion tu dégages